la mañana de este miércoles comenzó en
el reclusorio norte de la ciudad de
mexico la audiencia en la que el juez
definirá la situación jurídica del ex
procurador general de justicia jesús
murillo karam acusado de los delitos de
tortura desaparición forzada y contra la
administración de justicia en caso de
ser hallado culpable el ex funcionario
podría alcanzar una sentencia de más de
70 años de cárcel ya que tan solo el
delito de desaparición forzada amerita
una pena que va de los 40 a los 60 años
de prisión no obstante dada su edad los
74 años que obtiene y las enfermedades
que padece como hipertensión arterial y
enfermedad pulmonar obstructiva crónica
el exfuncionario podría haberse
beneficiado con la prisión domiciliaria
sin embargo esto quedará a criterio del
juez si bien el presidente lópez obrador
había dicho hace un par de días que él
mismo se había autoinculpado jesús
murillo al asumirse como responsable de
la investigación fallida este miércoles
ha dicho que tiene derecho a la defensa
que deben escucharse sus alegatos y lo
llamó a que diga la verdad
de por qué se ocultó la información
sobre la desaparición de los estudiantes
de ayotzinapa dijo que si no fue murillo
quien dio la orden entonces que él diga
quien ordenó ocultar estos datos y que
llevaron a la invención de la llamada
verdad histórica